اسمعني على ما يبدو هناك بعض المشاكل في
التواصل واياك كيف تبدو اذا الاوضاع حيث
انت
نحن الاوضاع هنا في جنوب الخرطوم في هذا
تبدو وكانها عاديه يحاول المواطن الان
الاستفاده من الهدنه وفي نفس الوقت
التعايش مع الوضع خاصه وان اللافت اليوم
في هذا السوق هنالك انخفاض في الاسعار
لربما بوفره المعروض من هذه المنتجات او
لربما بقله السيوله في هذه في هذه في هذا
السوق ولكن يمكننا معرفه هذه الاسباب
يعني اليوم ما هو الذي لفت نظرك في هذا
السوق والله اليوم السوق الوضع عامل جدا
جدا وما شاء الله الحضاره كلها شغاله
والسوق شغال وسفريات شغال والوضع في
كالعقله ما شاء الله كل اسعار الاسعار
والله مناسبه مناسبه جدا الطماطم ب 400
وكيلو البطاطس ب 300 ولا السوق عندنا
الاسعار لعليه شديد ولا منخفض جديد وسط
اسعار كويسه يعني
بمناسبه ان شاء الله
هذه واحده من الانطباعات الذين يقومون
بمحاوله جلب موادهم الغذائيه ومعرفه طبعا
الاسعار قبل يومين كان هنالك ارتفاع في
الاسعار بسبب ربما ندره المعروضه او بسبب
يعني التراب وكذلك الرغبه الكبيره
للمواطنين للحصول على احتياجاتهم ولكن
اليوم يمكننا هذا احد المواطنين ايضا يعني
ياخذ اغراضه يستفيد من الهدنه معه خبز
وكذلك بعض الاقراض كيف وجدت السوق وما هي
كيف الاسعار والله الحمد لله اليوم كويسه
والله حقيقه يعني يعني الليله الطماطم انا
مشتريها ب 300 جنيه كنت بشتريها بالف جنيه
كان بالف ونصف يعني في انفراج واضح والله
حتى الخبز يعني الخبز انا وقفت هسه يعني
زمن وجيزه اخذت خبز
بصراحه يعني
الامور متيسره يعني ما عدا انه الشارع بس
واقف
كل ما انجزوك هنا بيقدر يتناول حج
اذا نحاول المواطنون هنا في هذا السوق
الحصول على احتياجاتهم من المواد الغذائيه
من الخضروات من غير وعلى الرغم من ان كانت
يعني الشكوى في الايام السابقه
بندره
النقود او قله السيوله بسبب تعطل
التطبيقات البنكيه والاوضاع بصفه عامه كيف
وجدت الاسعار كيف هو اللي هي الاسعار كيف
تعيشين الان الاوضاع في الحرب
والتخوف المواطنين ولكن يخرجون ياتوا الى
سوق لشراء بعض الاحتياجات
هذه يعني تشاهدون مثلا هذه الطماطم بعض
السلع يعني
المتوفره الان مختلف الاسعار يعني ايضا
نسالك كيف وجد
يعني في في كثير من في من الاحوال يعني
كيف انطباعكم اليوم على السوق وشراء
المواطنين لبعض احتياجات والله الحمد لله
ماشي الحال ترى هذا وزي ما انت شايف السوق
يعني الحمد لله الوضع ما هو لكن
الحمد لله قاعدين يعني
ماشي الامور ماشي والحمد لله في امان
والله لكن بس
طبعا نشاهد ايضا على هذا الجانب مثلا على
هذا الجانب مثلا الخبز في هذا الفرن على
الرقم من ان هنالك يعني طوابير للخبز ولكن
يقول المواطنين انهم في نهايه المطاف
سيحصلون على ما يحتاجونه من الاحتياجاتهم
في الخبز تشاهدون الان
ان تشاهدون الان العدد من المواطنين يقفون
امام هذا المخبز للحصول على
احتياجاتهم وكذلك يعني كيف الوضع الان
المواطن يستفيد من الهدنه عشان ياخذ كثير
من الاحتياجاته ويرجع كيف تعيشتم مع هذه
الاوضاع نعم الاوضاع عندنا هنا في
الكلاكله نحمد الله يعني من بدايه
الاشتباكات والاوضاع هذه تماما ليس هناك
اي تفلتات والسبب لانه لا توجد اي معسكرات
او اي تجمع عسكري في هذه المنطقه او او
حواليها يعني الا معسكر طيبه وهو بعيد
يبعد كل البعد عن هذه المنطقه
نعم هناك اصوات متفرغه حين وحينا والناس
يعني تعود على هذه الاصوات وليس هناك اي
اي خوف حتى الناس بدات تتعايش مع هذه
الاصوات حتى الاطفال الصغار تعالوا نزل
الله ان يديم الامن والسلام على هذه
المنطقه يعني يمكن واحده منها الاسباب
الرئيسيه اللي خلت هذه المنطقه يعني او
جعلت هذه المنطقه في الكلاكله ان بعدها من
مناطق الاشتباكات ولذلك يحاول اي مواطن
قريب من هذه المنطقه تلمز اشياء احتياجاته
في ظل هذه الهدنه وكذلك هنالك اخرين يعني
يعبروا الى الولايات المجاوره او المناطق
الاخرى ثم ياتون يعني مثلا كيف انت تتعايش
مع اجواء الحرب في تحركاتك الاستفاده من
الهدنه والله يا اخي الشارع فاتح يعني انا
سافرت لحد الحصاحيصه
لحد الحصاحيصه ما في اي حاجه في الشارع
كانت الوضع طبيعي مع انه كنا بنسمع انه
الشارع ما امن وكذا الوضع طبيعي سافرت
ووصلته ومجيت راجع في نفس الوقت الوضع
طبيعي حتى قدامنا لقينا العربات شاحنه
الشاحنه طماطم والشاحن فالوضع طبيعي اي
نعم فيه في الشارع في دعم سريع لكن عربات
بعيده شويه من الزلط وفي الزلط بيكون في
نفرين ثلاثه انفار واقفين في الزلط كويس
لكن ما عندهم علاقه بالعربات
المواطنين فما تعرض للمواطنه والاسواق
الان الاسعار والله الاسعار شايفه طبيعي
نحن الاسعار طبيعيه بس كان في في استغلال
من التجار الفتره اللي فاتت
كيلو تمام استغلال نحن منا لو فينا احنا
البلد تتصلح تمام لكن نحن زادنا كشعب
المفروض نتصلح يعني الاستقلاليه من التجار
اكثر من اللازم يعني الواحد فينا الواحد
بيعل حاجه ب 500 بيجي بيقول لك والله
الحاجه ب2000 وهي الحاجه متوفره ب
البلد تتصلح كيف كده اذا كان في ازمات
شكرا جزيلا كيف الوضع الان انت تاتي للسوق
لشراء بعض الاحتياجات للبيت والله الوضع
قادم تماما انا عندك كلمتين بس اقولها لا
يغير الله مغيره بابنا انفسهم تمام يا اخي
احنا واقفين من قبل تمام بيقفل بينزل
الباب بيبيعوا التجارب هناك لين الاستغلال
ده يعني يحكي له الدقيق
اي حاجه متزايده يعني حاجه بالف جنيه
بيقول لك عادي
هذا جزء من
الانتباعات المواطنين في ظل هذه الهدنه
الذين يحاولون يعني الحصول على احتياجاتهم
من المواد الغذائيه وغيرها يعني وان كانت
هنالك انخفاض في الاسعار في الخضر ولكن
البعض يعزوه لكثره العرض وشحال السيوله
والبعض الاخر يرى ان هنالك يعني يعني
انتهى او المواطن استطاع ان يمتص الصدمه
الاولى ويتعايش مع الاوضاع وان كانت هنالك
ما تزال بعض الازمات والحياه يعني يصيبها
الشلل بسبب الحرب وهم يدعون ايضا لوقف هذه
الحرب ومحاوله يعني بسط الامن والاستقرار
وحل الازمات عن طريق الحوار وسياسيا نعم
الطاهر المرضي طبعا جميله نسمع صوت
المواطن السوداني وهو يتحدث عما يشغل في
هذه الظروف الاستثنائيه شكرا جزيلا لك
طاهر